so therefore i can say
up here when i pair this with this oh
sorry this
with this i should say this is this
complex number paired up with its
conjugate i should say
this equals 2 times the real component
of
that complex number e to the i
2 pi on 9. right
that's going to be what happens when i
this is what i get
from this term and this term this is
this is the conjugate right here so
i might just highlight that in blue so
you can see where i've
gotten that from okay so
that's where i get that from and all the
rest of the terms sort of follow suit
right so this is two times
the real component of and i'm going to
take
this 4 pi on 9 leave that the same but
the next one
i can actually do a teeny bit of
simplification here so this is the real
part
of e to the i i'm going to write this as
2 pi on
3 because i know what the
real part of edi 2.3 is it's just going
to be cosine
of 2.3 which is just a a simple exact
value i know
i'm almost there i've got 2 times the
real component of
this last term what am i up to 8 pi over
9
that's all equal to negative 1. so at
last this is my final step right i've
still got all this complex number stuff
flying around but because i have said
i'm now just going to take the real
components i can now just write this
completely in terms of cosines so i'm
going to have
you know what i i'm going to write the 2
cos 2 pi 9 here i can see i've got this
common factor of 2 all the way through
so
i'm going to factorize that shortly i've
got
2 cos 4 pi on 9
i know what cos of of 6 pi 9 is it's cos
of 2 pi on 3 which last i checked was
negative a half so that gives me 2 times
negative
a half here which you can see is going
to cancel shortly
and then 2 cos 8 pi r
9 equals negative 1. all right things
are looking good i'm going to
divide through by 2 so that gives me cos
of 2 pi over 9 cos of 4 pi over 9
i've got my negative or minus a half
here
i've got my cos 8 pi on 9 there and then
because i divided everything by 2
i've got negative a half there as well
and i notice that if i just add half to
both sides i get that term cancelling so
this is very promising right
i've got this term
and make sure i leave enough space and
then i've got this term
and this equals zero and this looks
fantastic it looks looks so close
to what i want to get except you then
just cast your eye back because you
always got to check like
i've done a lot of simplifying but have
i actually got what i asked for
was asked for i've got my times 2.9 i've
got my cos 4 pi and 9.
i do not have cos of pi or 9 nor do i
have it over here on the right hand side
i have 0 on the right hand side
what's going on here now at this point
here you might be able to say oh ok i
know what's happening
identity wise i can see how i can change
the cos 8 pi
9 that i've got into something
resembling this cos cosplay and i can do
simplification
but maybe you don't see it immediately
and so what i'm going to do here is
because we haven't looked at it for a
little while
i'm going to use an identity um that
relates to this and and enables me to
change my cos
pi 9 to my cos pi on 9 or related term
in a fairly seamless way but without
sort of pulling a rabbit out of a hat
how is 8 pi on 9 related to pi online
which is the term i've got related to
the term that i want
the answer is cos of a pi over 9 is the
supplement
of sorry 8 pi 9 just the angle itself is
the supplement
of pi on 9. so therefore i can write
i'll just
leave these terms out the front here in
fact i feel like i'm going to need this
space so i'll move back up i think i've
got
enough room here i'm going to write this
cos 8 pi or 9 i'm going to write it in a
somewhat
awkward form i'm going to write it as
cos pi minus pi on 9. you can see
that's that supplementary relationship
there it is the difference between
pi and pi on 9. that's what 8 pi 9 is
but this here is just the subject of a
fairly standard trig expansion that i've
got this is in the form cos of a
minus b so therefore i can write it as
cos a cos b plus sine a
sine b so these terms here remain
unchanged at the front
but i'm going to write cos pi cos
pi on nine plus sine pi
sine pi on line so this is my standard
expansion of this
cos a minus b term in fact what i'll do
is just to make it really clear
not deleted that's not what i want just
to make it really clear
where these terms have come from you can
see that is the expansion that leads me
to here okay now what can i do here well
thinking back to my simple graphs right
cos of pi
the graph of cos starts at one and by
the time it goes halfway through the
period i'm down to negative one
and that then sort of likewise sine pi
it starts at zero it goes up
comes back down to zero so this term
will equal negative one
this term will equal zero so i'm going
to get
once once again for good measure this
term
a pair of terms out the front this will
become minus
cos of pi on nine and this becomes zero
and now
at last to get what i want i'm going to
add
cos pi 9 to both sides so what that will
leave me with
is this term over here but instead of
minus it's going to be
equal to cos pi 9 on the right hand side
this
this is as required
[Applause]
take a breath well done so what did we
do here before we go on to the final
part
we had to recognize number one how to
use
part b i'm putting in this omega but
putting in a different form just to make
it easier to use
we had to recognize some stuff with
conjugates here and that
using conjugates was our way to get rid
of the imaginary
components all of them to get to this
line with all of our cosines and then we
had to do a little bit fiddling with
some exact values
and also with this uh this sort of
extension one trigonometric identity
here
so now we're ready for part d it says
deduce that cos pi 9 cos 2 pi 9 cos
4 pi 9 equals this now you'll notice
that unlike with parts a
b and c there seems to be a much more
clearer line of logic
part a comes from here part b this
factorization
the only way you can get to this thing
with you know the eighth power is from
this thing with the ninth power you can
see the way we factorize it
um and then part c just tells you hence
you have to use part b
to get to part c but then in part d they
kind of say
hey uh here's this other result you've
got the same angles cos pi
9 plus 2 pi 9 cos 4 pi 9 but what is the
relationship between this
and a b and c well in fact as you're
about to see
we don't have to use the results in a b
and c at all to prove part d it just
seems kind of nice that we can relate
these
it's sort of like something to do with
the sum of these angles and something to
do with the product so how am i going to
do this
i'm just going to do this in the way
that a classical trigonometry identity
has done which is
have a look at my left hand side my
right hand side think about which one is
more complicated and then
try and simplify from there the left
hand side is a mess
right hand side is just the number so
i'm going to start with the left hand
side
so what i've got is that's the next
question i'm going to do i think i need
an extra page
now do me okay so this is part d
um what i'm required to prove is that
cos pi on 9 cos 2 pi
9 cos 4 pi over 9.
i think i'm supposed to prove that
that's equal to an 8 let's just double
check
yeah looks good okay so how are we going
to do this well
i'm going to begin with the left hand
side because as we've noticed many times
before
our brain is pretty good at simplifying
complicated things because that's what
we spend a lot of our time
doing in maths not so good at
complicating
simple things though some might argue
we've been doing that a lot in complex
numbers this topic
so how do i have a go at this well what
i'm going to say is there's a
trigonometric identity
that allows me much like here to deal
with
this product of cosines i've got three
that looks a bit weird i'm going to have
to do this a couple of steps at a time
but the result that is going to help me
here is going to be the product of
two different cosine terms here you can
see
if i've got cos a times cos b it's equal
to half because of the difference
because of the sum and i'm going to have
to do this a couple of times because
i've got so many terms here
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start with these two terms over here on
the
left hand or the right hand side rather
i'm going to choose this
as my a this as my b and essentially
what is
a a minus b what is a plus b it's this
is the difference between a and b
this is the sum of a and b so i'm going
to use that as a simplified way
to write this so yeah i'm just going to
keep on going so this is cos pi on 9
hanging out the front and then in place
of this
product i'm going to write this sum here
so it's going to be
multiplied by a half uh here comes so
because of the difference in the first
place what's the difference between 4 pi
and 9
and 2 pi on 9 it's just 2 pi on 9.
that's the difference and then i'm going
to do the sum so that's going to be
plus cos of 6 pi on
9. now i noticed this before this is 2
pi on 3. so this is relatively easy
to simplify out with an exact angle
right um
let's let's keep going but i've got this
half sort of buzzing around the front
um cos pi on nine uh this cos two pi
over nine i don't have an exact value
for that so i'm just going to leave it
cos of six pi over nine is cos two pi
and three which i saw earlier on
is minus a half so that gives me that
term there
and so now i'm going to have to expand
again so what have i got here
i'm going to have this this pair here so
it's going to be in fact
i just write it without the parentheses
in the middle
so that's what i get from the first one
and then on the end i'm going to have
minus a quarter cos pi on
9 so that's from a half cosplay 9 times
negative a half
so that's looking good and what i'm
going to do is a second time i'm going
to use this same identity
i've got another cos a cos b so i'm
going to do this difference in some
business one more time so watch out
you've got a half already out the front
and that's multiplied by a half and then
i've got
cos of the difference which in this case
the difference between these two is
pi on 9
and then i'm going to have the sum right
so that's the a plus b
over here the sum of pi 9 and 2 pi over
9 is 3 pi
on 9. so again this is going to be a
nice exact value because
cos of 3 pi 9 is cos of pi on 3 which
i'll come to shortly
and then this term is still hanging out
on the end
here all right let's start to tidy up
this mess
a half times a half is a quarter
multiplied by cos
pi on nine that's promising because i've
got the minus a quarter cos pi and nine
at the end
and then what have i got here i've got
plus
a quarter what did we say cos pi on 3 is
that's
a half isn't it so i've got a half here
i'll put that in brackets just to
separate it out
and uh one more time here that minus
a quarter cos pi 9 is uh there at the
end so
i've got this term which is exactly
going to cancel with this term
so this equals a quarter times a half
which is
an eighth as required so look ma
no complex numbers um i just used
the result that they handed to me and
then i i worked
very methodically with this identity uh
using the difference in some of those
angles
so in summary when you have a look at
questions like this right don't be
intimidated
it does look weird when you have a look
at this off the face of it like where do
i
begin but think about all the knowledge
you have access to your trigonometric
identities which you've seen me used
repeatedly
the periodicity of trig functions which
is something we take advantage of
in complex numbers over and over again
you saw me do it in part a
and also in part b when i was no sorry
part c when i was simplifying things out
so these these sort of foundational
building blocks are really important to
you know free up your brain to then
complete you know sort of focus on the
complicated parts
uh the complex numbers that you've seen
in this question